hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Randy price
so we're gonna watch the trailer for
Star Wars Episode V do Star Wars Episode
7 trailer George Lucas is special
edition I don't know if this is a parody
video or George Lucas was like you know
what I'm gonna get involved
there has been everything have you felt
it
side and straight association
do you get a break special-effects
overload too much crap going on and then
uh the first baby you see like an animal
but yeah like what happened I am so
confused
the most accurate George Lucas thing I
saw was when Anakin Skywalker Hayden
Christensen appeared as the good I think
that's when I was like this is my
favorite little desert just like tone it
down George are you creating a fence
with you that's clever that's clever
yeah cuz they just and that was good
effects I don't know how they did that
like me yeah I should throw everything
in there perfectly they probably worked
on the effects before and then through
them and they layered it cuz you can do
that on like premiere or final cut
oh yeah I know these things I know these
things well I'm not gonna lie I'm still
like [ __ ] that was the actual trailer I
probably still check the movie out just
for shits and giggles what'd he say well
what did I totally miss it cuz I think I
was laughing when the lightsaber wizard
and straight negotiations
Treena gooshie yes oh yeah I was like he
said something weird that's true there's
a lot of that [ __ ] in the last lecture
to me that was out that was a delight to
watch it was fun if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects we're so [ __ ] awesome that's
why you should do it super cool we are
look at our thumbnail it's a film reel
on fire because we're rejected and
Brandi has a channel to show to start a
movie review soon and there'll be more
than that but check it out check it out
let love bleed red 97 it's a female
Brandi were rare female subscribers so
crazy she has pretty hair but her eyes I
feel like are staring into my soul
Ryan I frickin adore you guys so much I
feel as if you all have the same
reactions as I do for the most part you
guys are awesome and you and Veronica
are my OTP octopus tits penis for life
yes stay golden stay real that's with an
E and give me a shoutout
maybe love you guys let love bleed red
97 you're full of joy and beauty
you're an angel spread your wings fly
Red Bull helps because it gives you
class a comedy for you and we adore you
so thank you for adoring us I would hit
on you but I have a girlfriend now so I
don't do that anymore
but that's what I used to do for all
female subscribers yeah but know that I
think you are a kind gentle human being
and you're not hitting on you way you're
how do I say this without my girlfriend
get you're not bad-looking no way that
sounds offensive to you you are okay
you're you're looking keep it that way
David Botello yo Ryan love your vids all
guys are my favorite young y'all guys
y'all guys okay I probably was saying
all guys in general or his favorite
YouTube channel y'all guys can I have a
[ __ ] shoutout
she can't David but teleca's you my
mother [ __ ] on what I'm Michael Jackson
not even good I'm not even a good
Michael Jackson I was like bad Michael
for sure everything bad Michael get it
cuz you know I'm bad dad who's bad
David Patel is the one who's bad yes
hello patella he's Italian I could tell
by the oh people think I stereotype
people too much especially my race but I
could tell you are full Italian David is
also a very common name in Sicilian
culture actually did you know
Sicilians David were there were Italians
and then there were the Moors almost
black people look bad if I say this
watch true romance Christopher Walken
gives a monologue about it and that's
how I know history
he listens to Christopher Walken in a
movie and David Vitello is part of that
history
we're probably related regain turn and
Eze you guys are [ __ ] awesome can I
have a shot up please also where's cat
yes Henrique you can't have a shadow
Andrey gave me that's my impression of
all Hispanic people I don't people think
I'm a racist so I try to do very
accurate impressions so accurate Enrique
Hernandez si I come from the streets
vato what streets Lankershim a Magnolia
I hang out at the metro staying out of
the metro station by the big fire me cat
is um she moved far away that's why she
can't come on the channel as much for my
understanding she's still great I don't
pay attention to a single word cat says
I only listen to her when I was single
now I'm like words in my ears here I
know she doesn't watch these videos
that's why I'm gonna insult her as much
as I want it's kind of surprising that
you have any friends at all
I